i want to think about the mindset of how
you approach a question
okay not just are you good at math but
can you work out what's the way that you
sort of like you know like in basketball
right if you want to do a layup the
approach is everything
like it's literally everything the final
step that's just like it's the cherry on
top
it's how you get there that's important
okay so let me give you two tips and
i'll show you
uh how they work with an actual example
okay so here's my first tip
they say in real estate the most
important thing is location location
location
well when it comes to math questions
most important things are
details details details okay write down
details draw attention to them i'll show
you an example
you'll see how i mean right the second
thing is
pay very close attention to what's
actually being
asked by the question there'll be all
this data all this information that'll
help you answer it
and then at the very end or maybe at the
very start there will be
the question what they really want to
ask
so let's have a look this is a question
from the general maths paper for the hsc
last year
okay uh and you can see it's kind of um
it's financial maths of some kind
right jack's borrowing some money wants
to buy a house
he's got some um he's got some interest
on the loan and he has to repay stuff
okay now here's the first thing okay
details detail now someone tell me
what's the first
important detail first important detail
you can see the question
any takers three hundred thousand
dollars right there
you're like it's pretty easy it comes up
soon um and
i think that's we're gonna need that to
answer the question yeah okay what's the
next piece of information that's
important
probably the next thing you're going to
say is 1798
and so on right okay so the first thing
is
the numbers are going to be important
okay but
but remember i said details details
details it's not just the numbers can
anyone tell me
what's an important detail on there
that's not a number can anyone pick one
out there's tons
yeah sorry boro okay so firstly
he's not he's not a creditor he's a
debtor okay so he's a boy that's
important yeah up the back
monthly thank you compounded monthly
right yeah well done okay yeah another
one per anna
okay well where are you
can you see i know it's a maths question
right
but to understand it you need to pay
tons of attention
to the words there's a lot of verbal
detail there okay
now second thing right what's actually
being asked that's what i wanted you to
pay attention to
what is being asked yeah will you be
able to pay off the loan
so this question here right will he be
able to power the loan in 20 years
it's a yes no question isn't it yes or
no and then you have to
justify that means explain or prove it
to me you say yes or you say no
why right so now here's what i would do
okay
we've got these you told me right oh
important details you're like
three hundred thousand dollars and then
six percent
and then uh one seven nine eight and six
five and so on and so on
okay now you take all those numbers
right and then you put them together in
some kind of formula and then you're
like aha
now i have something to solve there's
like an x or an n or something like that
okay you get to the end okay and then
you'll solve it you get something like
oh n
equals 15 and you're like ah yes
i finished it it looks like it's about
right it's nice and simple
i'm done move on to the next question
okay
and the problem was i might have got
something right maybe
n was you know how long will it how many
years will it take for jack to pay off
the loan the answer might be 15 years
okay that might be right but i have not
answered the question right whoever i
said to you before
like sometimes i'll get into exam and i
know how to do the maths
but i still get killed by the you know
this is four marks i might just get two
out of four and you do that a few times
and before you know it you fail the exam
okay so therefore pay attention to these
guys don't get lost in all the numbers
and equations
remember why you're doing them pay close
attention to the question